happy hiring friday from hugging face
it's emily here and i'm a little bit
under the weather today so this video is
going to be short sweet and a little bit
different
i want to take a minute to talk about
the hidden job market have you heard of
it
the hidden job market refers to the fact
that an estimated 70 percent of open
roles are never posted or shared
publicly
do you get the iceberg reference
these jobs are most often filled through
referrals which means that networking is
really your only way to tap into this
market
while we do publicize our open roles we
are responsible for a small piece of the
hidden job market simply due to the fact
that if you are super good at what you
do we want to hire you even if there
isn't a job description that perfectly
fits your qualifications and experience
so i'd like to share some tips now on
how to effectively network and work to
get hired at hugging face
you can follow us on social media to see
all the latest and greatest we share new
tools and guides almost every day and
you can check out our blog for even more
detailed information
we also have a large and active
community on discord which is moderated
by a few folks on the hugging face team
i'd encourage you to become an active
member there
also if you're a machine learning
engineer
get to building
using our tools is a great start but
what's even more impressive is when you
can build something from the ground up
lastly and most importantly
apply
i know it sounds a little silly but if
you peruse our job openings and don't
see any that perfectly suit you but you
love hugging face and you know deep in
your soul that you can make a positive
impact here please apply using the wild
card position listed on our site we
would love to chat
this is by no means an exhaustive list
and i'd love to make more videos like
this soon is it helpful please let me
know
you can follow comment and share if you
want to learn more thanks have a great
weekend